Guys, I've already talked about this, but I want to talk about the questions and the
information that we push off until later.
There are a couple pieces of questions or a couple pieces of information that there's
a time and a place, and I want to go over those really briefly.
I've already talked about this, so I don't want to take too much time, but there's two
things.
As you start doing this live transfer process and you're calling them in between, you're
texting them in between, you're starting to build this relationship, they're going to
get comfortable with you and they're going to go...
Some of these guys are going to say, some of these ladies are going to say, hey, tell
me how much is this going to cost?
Just shoot me straight, man.
I'm a no BS kind of guy.
I'm a no BS kind of lady, and they're going to ask you, how does this work?
There are two things that you want to push off.
Number one is price and number two is deal structure because they're the two things that
can scare people.
I do not share either of those until the proper time.
I don't share the price until the final call.
I don't share the deal structure until the screencast, which is going to be in the next
module.
If these keep coming up, just keep letting them know, hey, I don't want to put the cart
before the horse.
We'll deal with that later.
Let me just get you a couple more leads and we can talk about it, but I'm very flexible.
Just so you know, I'm really creative.
I own this company.
It's on me.
I get to decide.
That's my go-to.
Nice.
I've mentioned this before, but if somebody keeps hitting you on price, price, price,
price, price, and it gets to the point where it's like, they're going to need no price,
just say, hey, just to be honest with you, Mr. Business Owner, Mr. Business Owner, I
have customers that are paying me three to 500 bucks a month and I have somebody that's
paying me 20, 30K a month.
It's going to be somewhere in between.
Ha, ha, ha.
No, but seriously, obviously it'll be way closer to the bottom than the top, but it's
a huge range.
There's a lot of factors.
I don't want to get too deep into that until we found out that this is actually a good
fit.
Okay?
This is something to satisfy them and move on.
That's it.
That's what I say if they keep hitting me on price.
Those two things, the deal structure, and this is something you're going to get a lot
as people are going to keep saying, and they're going to be trying to hedge their bet.
They're going to go, yeah, man, this is cool.
I'm just going to raise my prices and I'm going to give you 10% or, hey, this is going
to work out really well.
I'm just going to give you a percentage.
It's going to start to get to your head because you're going to think, man, how am I ever
going to sell this person on a flat fee deal?
Don't let it get to your head.
Don't get flustered.
Don't stop and go, hey, man.
I actually don't do commission.
Hey, man.
I don't do paper lead.
I only do flat fee.
You're going to spook them.
The time to bring up the flat fee is after you've explained why commission sucks and
why paper lead sucks during the screencast.
Let them talk.
Let them share.
Let them keep thinking they're going to get a commission deal.
Don't tell them they're going to get a commission deal.
Don't agree with them, but let them talk.
Don't get frustrated.
Don't get flustered.
Just realize what they're trying to do is they're trying to let you know that, hey,
They're comfortable paying a commission, but they don't want to do anything else.
But the thing is they don't understand.
They don't understand why paper lead actually sucks for them.
They don't understand why commission.
There's no incentive for either of you, but there's a time and a place.
I just wanted to mention once again, do not drop price too early.
Do not drop deal structure too early or you're going to kill the deal.
And I want to mention it here because as you start doing these live transfers, you're going
to have a lot of communication with the business owner and they're going to start asking questions.
They're going to get comfortable with you.
They're going to ask and be like, hey, bro.
So, you know, how's this going to work?
I know you want to share.
You want to jump ahead.
You want to sell the whole thing.
There's a time and a place.
You don't want to do it yet.
You want to push it off until the proper time.
We're going to get into that in future videos.